synagogue chabada odessa avant la guerre
elle accueillait jusqu'à 150 fidèles par
jour aujourd'hui seules deux ou trois
personnes viennent d'y prier oleksandr
qui m'a nommé l'un d'entre eux sa
famille a été évacuée mais lui restera
au dessin est très importante car les
juives ici depuis la fondation même de
la ville la plupart des écrivains des
poètes des peintres viennent de la
communauté juive
galina dimier beach à elle décidé de
partir pour retrouver son fils en israël
un exil au goût de déjà vu en 1942 elle
avait fui les nazis avec ses parents
sont mariés décédé le 24 février dernier
jour de l'invasion russe en ukraine
je remercie dieu de m'avoir permis
d'enterrer mon mari il est mort et n'a
pas eu à voir tout cela il n'y aurait
pas survécu cette mère de famille et ses
deux filles s'apprête elle aussi à
quitter l'ukraine
je veux ce près de chez moi je ne veux
pas aller loin une fois qu'on me dira
que c'est fini je vais pouvoir prendre
mes affaires et rentrer chez moi à pied
tous les jours ils sont des dizaines à
se rassembler devant la gare et
embarquent dans des bus ils quittent
leur ville sans savoir s'ils pourront y
retourner un jour